Microsoft co-founder and billionaire
philanthropist Bill Gates is urging the
federal government to shut down the
entire country to save lives so far the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation has
donated 100 million dollars to fight the
corona virus they're focused on
detection isolation and treatment of the
virus and finding a vaccine Kate says
the u.s. failed to get ahead of the
outbreak but it's not too late to make
up for lost time you've been saying for
a long time that we're not prioritizing
testing who should be leading the way
here well the federal government needs
to set the priorities because we have a
lot of people were just worried who
would like to get a test and if we had
infinite capacity that would be great
and so as many as half of our tests are
going to the people they shouldn't and
that's causing you'd have to wait often
three or four days even if your health
care worker to get that result back back
in 2015 you warned that we were not
ready for the next epidemic why have I
have aren't we better prepared well in
fact very little investment was made for
example being able to ramp up diagnostic
capacity very quickly our foundation and
some other governments did work on some
new vaccine platforms which are the most
promising but you know sadly because you
can't estimate the risk and it was
something I was you know trying to talk
about and you know thought we had some
engagement on but then actually the
personnel in this area were were cut
back you know I think this time people
understand that this is a trillions of
dollars event it's going to be hundreds
of thousands of lives on a on a global
basis I think now people understand why
those alarms were raised and that for
the next one we will be far more ready
than we were for this one ultimately did
the federal government fail on being
prepared for testing well I'm sure
there'll be lots of post-mortems of
you know why before this hit didn't we
do more why you know right when it hit
didn't we do more it's most important to
be looking forward and saying are the
number of tests growing is the speed
which they come back less than 24 hours
and are we testing the right people
we're still not there and so let's get
that fixed and then we can you know
maybe a year from now do the deep
post-mortems you also talked in 2015
about the potential economic
consequences of this how concerned are
you about the resiliency of the American
economy well the economy is being heard
it's great that Congress has acted we
probably will need to do more there but
the economy can return in a way that
people who get sick and die cannot
you've been in touch with leaders in
Washington have you talked with the
president about this I've not talked
directly to the president our foundation
is trying to be as helpful in a very
constructive way as possible and that's
why I've talked to the head of the
pharmaceutical companies we've talked to
a lot of the agencies including CDC and
NIH about how we work together on the
vaccine and the drugs is there anything
that's really surprised you about what's
happened you know I thought we would
respond a bit faster
what we're doing how we're having to
change the economy here in order to drop
the number of cases it's you know it's
really unprecedented even the issue of
once you get the case numbers down
what does opening up look like you know
which activities like schools have such
benefit and can be done in a way that
the risk of transmission is very low and
which activities like mass gatherings
may be in a certain sense more optional
and so until you're widely back saying
that those may not come back at all do
you think we're we're gonna think about
pandemics differently from now on well
that is for sure you know there were a
few movies they weren't that popular
about this and to make them at least a
little bit popular they usually have
some miracle happen at the end where
some hero you know invented something
and boom everything was back to normal
no the awareness of this is a threat and
probably the biggest threat to you know
kill tens of millions of people that
will be permanently embedded so this
time I do think we will get ourselves
ready for the next pandemic have you had
any trouble getting adjusted to social
distancing at home yeah I find it so
disconcerting to wake up every morning
and think well that was a strange dream
I had and then say oh my god yes you
know look there's no traffic on the
bridge and oh yeah my first meeting is
on that computer screen and when
somebody's gonna leave some food but I
won't see them this is super dramatic
you know I use computer screens a lot
and I think about pandemics a lot and
even so I can hardly believe we're in
this situation Gate says he thinks we
could feel the effects of this well into
the summer and the economic effects
could linger for perhaps as long as two
years depending on how comfortable
people are mingling together until we
have a vaccine no Anthony I think we are
forever change by this on so many
different levels I was fascinated by
Bill Gates answer when you said do you
think the government did they not do
enough his answer was very diplomatic
but clearly he saw something into 2015 I
marvel that he saw something back then
we laid out the threat very Kerala
clearly then Galen
yes yes he's a very smart guy has a lot
of experience I'm thinking of any way I
might take that call he's offering his
his services I'd be calling him you can
hear my extended interview with you can
hear my extended interview with Bill
Gates on CBS this morning's podcast or
watch it at CBS this morning calm